[Musique]
laurie vient de commencer ses études
universitaires
quelques semaines après avoir payé ses
frais de scolarité elle se rend compte
que la facture inclut une assurance qui
la couvre cours des soins de santé de la
vue et des soins dentaires
mais laury est déjà couverte par les
assurances collectives de sa maman et
n'a pas besoin de cette nouvelle
assurance qui lui crie plus de 300 $
pour l'année
elle demande à l'université si elle peut
annuler cette assurance innus et 10 mai
l'université refusant le riz avec quatre
semaines au début de la session pour le
faire maintenant il est trop tard lors y
avait la tête assez court et n'a pas
pris le temps de lire ses papiers
d'assurances elle aurait vu quelle
université les assurances ouvre une
petite porte aux étudiants qui n'ont pas
besoin de s'assurer mais elles se
referment bien vite le fin mot de
l'histoire
vous n'avez que quelques semaines pour
décortiquer vos frais de scolarité
faites le sans tarder si vous voulez
économiser